Đoàn sức quá trình lãnh đạo cách mặt, đàn công sản vịch náp luân quán trẻ quán điểm quần chúng nhân dân,
lãng ơi lắm nên lix sử, cách mạng là sự nghiệp của quần chúng nhân dân.
Dù tịch hòi chi Minh khẳng địch trong bầu trời không gì quy bản nhân dân, trong xá hội không có gì tốt đẹp về văn bằng phục vụ cho lợi ít quả nhân dân.
Gốc có bứng, cây mới bệnh, xây lòng tháng lợi trên nền nhân dân.
Bối được lỗi chính trị đúng đánh, Trung thành vô hạn với lợi ít quả sân vào và gái cất,
lãnh bó mấu thiệt với nhân dân. Đàn luôn nhất quán khẳng định vái trò quán trọng của nhân dân,
lãnh lực lợi quyết định mọi tháng lợi của tính trình xây dựng và phát triển đất nước.
Tự thảo báo cánh chính trị của bán chấp hành trung ngân đạn khoảng người bà,
tại hội đại biểu văn khó lần thứ mời bốn của đàn tiếp tục nhấn mạnh tư tưởng chính lợi dân là gốc.
Phát triển vái trò chủ thẻ bị chiến trung tâm của nhân dân, lấy sự hai lòng tính nhận của người dân dân nhập và hiệu quả công việc làm điều chỉ đánh ra cám bộ.
Tăng cường cùng khó và phát triển, theo quả sức mạnh của nhân dân và khối đại loàn kết tòàn dân.
Những thành thực con lớn sau 4 năm đổi mới chính là kết quả của ý chi quyết tâm cao sự nỗ lực phân đấu
loàn kết trung sức nồng lòng của cả hệ thống chiến trị và quan đàn quan dân tòàn quân tà.
Đông thời gỗ lần mình chính trật sức mạnh của khối đại loàn kết tòàn dân tòng và việc phát vi mạnh mẽ vái trò chủ thẻ.
Vì chiến trung tâm của nhân dân trong phát triển đất nước.
Nhìn lại 5 năm thực hiện nghị quyết đại hội mời bà của đàn.
Có thể thẳng định, Nhật Khi hai Ninh không trọng 2 mi mốt 2 mi, là một trọng đường đây thử thách những cố gý rấu nhiều kết quả quan trọng, toàn dị và có ý nghĩa lo dài.
Tăng trường dưỡng dưỡng 3 mi, đặt tắm phải không 2 phải trọng,
mình quân ra đoạn 2 mi, không trọng 2 mi mốt 2 mi, là một khu vật 3 mi, là sấu phải 3 phải trọng.
Thục nhóm cao của khu vực và trị thế giới.
Một mình chính tiêu biểu gần đánh, khai hiện gió chủ chương lấy nhân dân lạch chút tâm của khoái trình hoạt định chi sách,
là nơi sinh hoạt chính trị lấy ý kiến của khán bộ đàn viện và các tự lấp nhân dân và giữa thảo các phân kẹn chiến đại hội mời bốn của đàn.
Qua đật lấy ý kiến dọng giải này, đàn không chỉ tiếp tù chỉ tùi tội của tòa dân.
Mà con khẳng định quân chấp dân biết dân bản dân lạng dân kiểm tra dân giám xác và dân thủ hợp.
Tụng gố mối quan hệ ngán bó mấu thị dựa đàn bối nhân dân.
Chóng các bạn biết phát biểu, tổ mi tư tô lâm quán chiến xấu xác quan điểm, kiến định lập trường quan điểm và thơ khai dân lạng lốc.
Nhân dân là chủ hệ chung tâm của con quốc lỗi mới.
Mọi chủ chương chính xác phải thực sự xất phát từ cuộc sống quyền bỏ quyền và lợi ý chính đáng của nhân dân.
Lấy hạnh phúc ấm nò của nhân dân là một thiêu phân đấu bảo đàn mọi người dân nèu được thủ hợp những thành quả của tôi mới, phát triển được sống hạnh phúc trong môi trường ăn linh ăn toàn không ai bị bỏ lạng phía sau.
Bỏ thẻ khẳng định phát triển và trò chủ hệ vị chiến chung tâm của nhân dân chính là nên tảng tiếp tục khẳng định và bảo đàn cho sự chương tôn của chế độ.
Lần đầu lực nè đất nước vững mức tiến mạnh bảo kỳ quyền mới, phát triển sau mạnh thịt bởg.